it not taken long for the Turkish
military to begin their troop deployment
through the day tanks have been moving
south along the road to the Syrian
border soldiers have been moved to the
border towns in fleets of coaches other
equipment - in just 36 hours since the
US president stepped aside militarily
diplomatically and controversially
giving space for his ally Turkey to
attack his other ally the Kurds
artillery is in place at strategic
locations along the border sights set on
the Kurdish positions on the other side
for Turkey the enemy over there are
terrorists they wanted to destroy for
decades but they are the same people who
have been fighting the Islamic state
alongside the Americans and the British
and over the border in the Syrian town
of Qamishli they reminded the world of
that wounded Kurdish fighters marched
carrying posters of their dead comrades
past the UN offices their call was for
the international community to stop the
Turkish incursion it was a blunt message
for Donald Trump - we fought alongside
you we've almost defeated Isis don't
abandon us
and yet in Ankara the Turkish vice
president framed the incursion as
humanitarian in part a space to
repatriate Syrian refugees for the
chance to remove an enemy - Turkey will
not accept the creation of a terror
corridor or a terror State right next to
its borders under any circumstances
whatever the cost well they've been
coming down towards the border through
the day a couple more here now in the
sense that we're getting is that even if
Donald Trump does decide to make some
sort of a u-turn here in Turkey this
time they really are ready to move in
but as the units gather president
Trump's yo-yoing has continued he's
warned against turkey overreaching with
disproportionate force but is it too
late another phase of this complicated
war could be closed
mark stone sky news on the turkey-syria
border